c'était en mai 2021 régine laurent
présentait 65 recommandations et 250
pistes d'action pour améliorer la
direction de la protection de la
jeunesse et prévenir d'autres morts
tragiques comme celle de la fillette de
granby survenu en 2019 leur charge de
travail devraient moins lourde afin
qu'elles puissent s'occuper adéquatement
des enfants et des familles la
commissaire suggéré entre autres de
mieux soutenir les professionnels qui
travaillent auprès des jeunes de la dpj
mais cette charge de travail n'a pas
diminué soutien syndicats même si québec
a annoncé la création de 500 postes si
vous améliorer pour les conditions pour
mettre ses 500 ou 1000 postes
supplémentaires ses prochains jeux on
n'est pas attractif dans les centres
jeunesse d'avoir déjà sa mère proche
d'eux qu'ils sont capables d orienter
dans vos du temps pour se former on est
pour se ranger des urgences est sous m
les familles d'accueil aussi doivent
être mieux soutenues mieux formés et
mieux valoriser la fédération des
familles d'accueil les ressources
intermédiaires de québec s'attendait à
lambeau d'intervenants capable
d'outiller ses membres selon les besoins
particuliers des enfants sa présidente
est déçu de constater que l'argent est
allé ailleurs sur le terrain mais ces
intervenants l'eau n'existe pas encore
ou dans certains cas le budget a été
utilisé en interne en contrôle qualité
qui ne correspond aux à notre avis l'eau
à la promesse faite par le ministre et
encore moins aux recommandations de la
commission le virage prévention c'est
obligatoire selon la commissaire les
organismes communautaires les ciel et
ses joue un rôle essentiel pour aider
les familles vulnérables afin de
prévenir le recours à la dpj mais les
délais sont encore trop long selon la
directrice générale du bureau de la
communauté haïtienne de montréal il faut
que lorsque la référence fff que le par
la famille n'est pas attendre une année
deux années pour recevoir des services
il ya l'urgence d'agir elle estime aussi
que québec doit sa clé au financement
des programmes d'accès au logement pour
les jeunes qui quittent la dpj
le ministre délégué à la santé et aux
services sociaux lionel carmant
présenteront au cours des prochaines
semaines un bilan de ce qui a été
réalisé son cabinet souligne que
plusieurs des recommandations ont été
mises en place à travers la loi qu est
ce qui vient modifier la loi sur la
protection de la jeunesse ici valérie
michael abeilles radio canada montréal